le groupe psa vient d'annoncer quelques
5 milliards de pertes pour 2012 avec
l'obligation de repenser le
positionnement de ses deux marques
peugeot et citroën pendant ce temps les
constructeurs étrangers semblent tirer
leur épingle du jeu c'est le cas de
mercedes une progression de 9% c'est ce
que vient d'annoncer le pdg du groupe
france lors de la pose de la première
pierre du nouveau siège social dans les
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux
zone d'activités du pas du lac de
montigny le bretonneux ce matin a eu
lieu la pose symbolique de la première
pierre du chantier du nouveau siège de
la marque en présence d'élus le coup le
star center c'est son nom en interne
regroupera plus de 700 collaborateurs du
siège de mercedes benz france
actuellement un roc en cours et sa
filiale financière de bailly ainsi que
le centre de formation de la courneuve
le campus s'étendra sur 20 mille mètres
carrés entre les avenues newton lips et
franklin le bâtiment gris sur la gauche
abritera la mercedes-benz academy centre
de formation où seront exposés aux
collaborateurs les nouveaux modèles de
camions vannes et voitures sur la droite
l'immeuble du siège social mesurera
environ 34 mètres de haut des stores
extérieurs habilleront les grandes baies
vitrées un concept novateur en france
autour 500 arbres seront plantés et une
rivière sèche pour gérer l'eau de pluie
aujourd'hui un parking souterrain de
plus de 400 places est déjà terminée des
exigences du client la rampe de parts
qui a été dimensionnée pour que 2000
bars puissent se croiser pour qu il ne s
et l'air ne frotte pas quand elle quand
elle franchira la rampe voilà c'est les
petits détails auxquels un promoteur au
quotidien n'est pas habitués mais ça
faisait plaisir d'avoir un utilisateur
qui était soucieux du détail de la
qualité de la construction ce nouvel
écrin de construction écologique
labellisé correspond aux ambitions de la
marque allemande
est tendue
sa position de manière tout à fait
encourageants en 12 plus elle est comme
ça en immatriculations de voitures une
croissance de nos clients pensent en
manche et en est finalement le mondial
90 euros l'accord majeur tous les
utilitaires merci de cette cérémonie
noir est arrivé à san francisco vie
notre objectif est d argile
marché opération séduction réussie pour
montigny le bretonneux 2013 est bel et
bien l'année des chantiers entre
l'arrivée du vélodrome la construction
de la gare routière urbaine et de
l'estaca école d'ingénieurs en
automobile à l'heure où des villes
perdent des entreprises nous nous en
gagnons ce qui est quand même le signe
de la grande attractivité de notre
agglomération et de la ville de
montigny-le-bretonneux la deuxième chose
aussi c'est le site du renouveau de la
zone d'activités du pas du lac livraison
prévue en janvier 2014 comme exigé par
la marque à l'étoile
et la marque mercedes justement que
représente l pour vous que signifie
justement cette marque est elle une
symbolique particulière le fait que ce
siège social viennent à saint quentin en
yvelines c'est la question que nous
avons posée le luxe certaines classes
que
non pas les voitures françaises par
exemple chez moi enfin moi
personnellement j'aimerais avoir une
mercedes plus tard l'allemagne
fiabilité solidité mais gros budget il
doit y avoir des ennuis comme comme dans
toutes les marques mais monsieur fiable
le luxe
le prestige et puis la marque allemande
et puis une marque une marque de voiture
qui a priori bas bien par rapport à nos
deux marques françaises je connais des
collègues qui en ont et qui trouve que
c'est quand même très raide la prochaine
fois ils font peut-être revenir une
voiture française plus souple un
la chronique culture ce soit avec trois
invités pour nous accompagner durant les
prochaines vingt minutes auraient lieu
de baisser et oui donc ce soir nous
recevons et igor lors du vidal vous êtes
toutes les deux donc comédienne metteur
en scène au sein de la compagnie
garde-fous et vous jouer ce week-end une
pièce qui s'intitule comment et vous
nous donnerez les réponses à quelques
minutes nous recevons également roland
nadeau bonsoir alors vous connaît sous
la casquette de l'homme politique de
l'élu à guyancourt mais ce soir vous
venez sous la plume du poète on a parlé
à quelques instants par de votre ouvrage
justement de votre dernier ouvrage
auparavant nous sommes mercredi on va
débuter cette chronique culture
forcément si vous vous pouvez bien par
les sorties ciné vos réactions à l'issue
des projections de ce matin toujours au
micro à d'elodie moines comme chaque
semaine juste un peu plus les fichiers
aussi bien c'était quand même un peu
long alors je trouvais qu'il ya quand
même des belles choses passent en panne
hathaway est magnifique elle allège en
outre en une seule chanson el maleh de
son oscar vraiment elle est très très
bien elle je mitigé c'est pas non plus
un gros navet comme j'ai pu lire mais
c'est pas non plus la grosse folie voix
voilà donc il faut aimer entend des gens
chanter pendant 2h30 sinon c'est sûr on
part au bout d'une demi-heure quoi les
comédies musicales
en film
j'ai pas trop aimé en fait les acteurs
jouent bien mais et c'est vrai que tout
du long
que de que des chances et c'est
particulier en fasse quelque chose
d'inespéré d'inattendu parce qu'on
pensait connaître cet acteur sous
d'autres angles et à la fin la le
revirement de situation a été plus que
surprenante j'ai bien aimé c'était pas
mal
bon on n'a pas un peu que c'est un peu
mélodrame enfin le côté américain sous
mais sinon c'était cool j'ai bien aimé
le personnage est assez fascinant est
tous un peu peu détruit un peu que par
la vie mais c'est cool ouais c gb mai